to tenth cities will open along the
southern border this week in response to
a record-breaking surge of migrants
crossing from Mexico Acting Homeland
Security Secretary Kevin miquelina
told Sharon el Fonzie on 60 minutes that
many migrants who cross illegally are
released in the US with no fear of being
sent home if you come now and if you
come as a family or as an unaccompanied
child you will be allowed to stay you
will be released because our court
system is so backlogged and our laws
prevent effective or patreon even if
there's no right to stay in the US they
know if they comes they're gonna be let
out the back time that's exactly right
and the smugglers are advertising that
Malaya VL is in Donna Texas near the
border with Mexico merely a good morning
the government's latest attempt at
dealing with that humanitarian crisis
right behind me there are already tent
set up and construction equipment ready
to go now guys this looks like a
familiar spot that's because I was
standing in this exact location about
six months ago when President Trump sent
the military down here to help with a
migrant caravan that never arrived
a makeshift base was set up in about a
week and the group was supposed to help
secure the border but it was gone within
a month in an interview with Fox News
this weekend President Trump referred to
immigration in the US as Disneyland he
implied everyone wants to come here and
things have gotten worse because we are
not separating children from their
parents to be clear however DHS
officials have said numerous times that
separation is still happening just not
at the capacity that we saw last summer
now we will be getting a first-hand look
at this facility tomorrow we will be
escorted in by DHS and CBP officials
these facilities one here in Donna one
in El Paso will hold up to 500 men women
and children all inside the facility
they will have beds toilets and
showering facilities as well John Maria
thank you